في 28 من يونيو حذرا من العام الماضي وقعت
تركيا والسويد وفنلندا مذكره تفاهم ثلاثيه
بشان انضمام البلدين الاخرين الى الناتو
مع تعاهدهما بالاستجابه لمطالب انقر بشان
التعاون في ملف مكافحه الارهاب تشتري
تركيا تسليم السويد وفنلندا اشخاصا تتهمهم
تركيا بان لهم صله بالارهاب واكرر رئيس
التركي ورجب طيب اردوغان مطربته بتسليم
حوالي 70 شخصا في هذا الاطار كما تطالب
انقر بانثر السويد بنفسها عن دعم حزب
العمال الكردستاني ووحده حمايه الشعب
الكرديه في شمال سوريا حيث تتهم السويد
وفي لندن بايواء مقاتلين منهما فضلا عن
عناصر من تنظيم جولن تسليم السويد لعضوين
في الحزب الكردي اليسرى في ارهابيا من
جانب انقره والاتحاد الاوروبي ومحكوم عليه
في تركيا اعتبرته انقره بدايه تنتظر ما
يليها لكنها عادت وعبرت عن خيبه املها بعد
رفض المحكمه العليا في ترحيل صحفيا تركي
تطالب انقر بتسليمه واتهمته بالطورط في
الانقلاب الفاشل الذي شاهدته البلاد عام
2016 وزير الخارجيه التركي صرح مره ان
السويد لا تزال مركز جذب لاعضاء تنظيم
جولن وضع السويد الى التعاون مع انقره في
مكافحه الارهاب دون الوقوع في مسماه
ازدواجيه المعايير